qu'ils sont là c'est en quelque sorte la
nouvelle plaque d'immatriculation de
besançon avec dans le véhicule une
famille toujours plus grande
68 communes réunies autour de besançon
un changement d'échelle surveillés de
près et en personne par la ministre de
la cohésion des territoires
vous savez parfois on utilise le terme
ruissellement parce que au fond il faut
pas qu'ils aient que les habitants de la
ville centre qui en bénéficient mais
l'ensemble des habitants qui vivent sur
le territoire cédé sur le bassin de vie
autour de meuse en sang fini donc le
grand besançon et son oiseau
vieillissant voici venu le temps de la
communauté urbaine
une décision prise à la quasi-unanimité
des 128 membres de l'ancienne c'est à gb
avec un budget renforcer notre budget
dépassant 2019 pour la première fois et
300 millions d'euros soit trois fois
plus qu'en 2001 et les pas sont les 70
millions d'investissements annuels ce
qui dans le contexte économique actuel
est loin d'être négligeable
besançon rejoint donc d'autres
communautés urbaines poitiers quand
limoges ici en rouge en bleu les villes
métropoles plus importante parmi elles
dijon est ce une astuce marketing
besançon s'appellera grand besançon
métropole
certains dénoncent une fuite en avant
les métropoles sont en train tout à
tirer sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs oui faut qu'on se batte pour
quoi regarder de l'attractivité à
l'intérieur de l'opéra mais notre
volonté par rapport à ça c'est dans un
équilibre général besançon qui
n'atteignaient pas le seuil des 250
mille habitants a bénéficié d'une
dérogation pour devenir communauté
urbaine dérogation attribués defacto aux
anciennes capitales régionales